we're still looking at fractals okay
this is only our second go at it i gave
you some five more complicated fractals
to build ones that were just impractical
to do on your own now with roundhouse
help i put together this one
do you recognize it we gave this a name
last time what's it called
this is c pizza's triangle right now
what's interesting is that it didn't
start with a triangle at all last time
you built it like this i think you you
had your triangle and then you did an
upside down triangle on that
and then you did upside down triangles
in those and and off you went from there
okay but this shape here right started
completely differently which is what
these ones are doing over here it
started
with a trapezium
okay i'll very quickly show you the
first couple of steps and you can see
maybe how it grew up right
i'm gonna use i've got three equal sides
on this trapezium and i use those three
equal sides as the base
to form new trapezium okay so for
example i've got a new trapezium down
here which is similar to the first one
i've got a new one up here which is also
similar to the first one so these two
are congruent and then i've got one in
here okay and then i've got more
trapezius to repeat the process and
that's how this thing built okay so you
can see that as i particularly as i
build these ones on top that's what what
gives you that sort of triangular shape
right but um c psk comes back invites us
again even though we started with
trapezium shapes okay so therefore this
idea of fractals and how they're
constructed here's the important idea
everything you've all been doing today
it's a it's a process it's called
iteration this is a massively important
idea that you need to get down okay
iteration
um
iteration is uh it's a noun uh in a
couple of different ways it can mean a
process or it means the results you get
from the process now this word iterate
means as you've been able to tell today
you take some idea some procedure and
you do it over and over again okay so
for example it was the construction of
those trapezes oh that's terrible sorry
um more and more trees over and over
again and then this shape emerges okay
or you had your triangle uh on them
start with triangles right and then what
you were doing was called barycentric
subdivision because you found what's
called the barycenter okay you divide it
up through angle bisection right then
you do a few more lines by angle by
section at the middle and now you've got
six triangles that you could do
barocentric subdivision again right so
for example over here it'll look
something like this then you divide up
those and now you've got six more
triangles and on and on and on okay so
iteration
is a repeated or here's another word for
you
or recursive
process
right you're doing the same process to
increasingly smaller subsets of
this picture we're doing it
geometrically
so what happens is we're going to move
next lesson from geometry
right we're not going to completely go
away from geometry but we're going to
think about it instead of draw this and
then bisect that okay we're going to
introduce this idea of iterated
function systems
okay even if you've never seen the
language before you know what functions
are functions are things like x squared
or the square root of x minus one these
are
things that you put a number in and
input x right and out comes something
else some other value this is a function
right and we're going to do them over
and over again and see what happens with
different kinds of functions